you just hit up them up be like yo we're
not cuz I I don't think they should buy
them but I do think they should hit them
up be like what's it going to take for
this to be only on our platform in in
Game Pass for as long as you guys are
around we just we just talked about why
this is not the greatest decision to
make like I don't know man like I I I
guess to to me like they they they don't
even really necessarily have to like
lock it down to a console exclusive it's
like just make make sure this never
leaves Game Pass like all right that
works all right all right no then you
hustling backwards right all right so
what you want give them give them as
much money as they need to get it okay
and then you can choose you can make
that choice whatever put it on PC